nous allons terminer taratata avec
claude cenci seulement claude nous nous
sommes penchés sur ton dernier succès
qui va interpréter ce soir nous l'avons
analysé et daniel prévost et moi même
qui avons fait le conservatoire national
de chant dans la classe de yaourt lui
trouve que la chanson tels que tu
interprètes manque si tu veux un peu de
nuance
ça manque de rubato de d'un certain
classicisme alors je ne te donne pas de
conseils mais voit tes aînés nous allons
interpréter la chanson et tu verras tout
de même qu'il ya quelque chose à en
tirer
attention attendez la fin de la séance
pour tomber les cintres alors c'est une
chanson populaire l'autre en soit un
rossi
santé
deux chansons
plus
hopla chante la hâte à façon et le
public choisira claude françois